tear the matt wall show media matters
and some others on the left were upset
by my analysis of the modern dating
scene apparently i'm told that my point
of view on the subject is old-fashioned
and reactionary and they're not
necessarily wrong about that also a
truck carrying infected monkeys from a
lab escaped from their cages during a
highway accident why are these labs
allowed to dump pathogens all over the
globe without any consequence that's a
question and robert f kennedy jr made a
holocaust analogy during his speech at
the anti-mandate protest on sunday and
yesterday his own wife came out and
denounced him for it plus camilla harris
lists the most vulnerable victim groups
in america and the list seems to have
expanded to encompass every group except
one of course and finally hollywood
actor peter dinklage says that the
dwarves in snow white are offensive and
the story only gets dumber from there i
promise you we'll talk about all that
and more today on the matte wall show
[Music]
reagan saw it 40 years ago massive
inflation that we haven't seen since
well
until today in his own words inflation
is as violent as a mugger as frightening
as an armed robber and as deadly as a
hitman right now your retirement
accounts are under attack thanks to the
inflationary policies of this current
administration if you have not yet
called birch gold the only people i
trust to help you diversify your 401ks
and iras into gold then you're missing
the boat actually you're treading water
without a life vest or a boat at all
birch gold has your life vest they're
here to help let them help you convert
an ira or 401k into a tax sheltered ira
in gold with thousands of satisfied
customers and an a plus rating with the
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to protect your savings text
walsh to 98 98 98 to get a free info kit
on gold reagan knew the biggest threat
to our wealth and uh this is what we're
solving protect yours now text walsh
again to 98 98 98 to get your free info
kit now
there's a little bit of a delayed
reaction but finally yesterday tuesday
the usual suspects decided to be
offended by my show on monday where we
talked about among other things the
perils of modern dating and as you might
recall during the course of that
conversation i observed that one of the
myriad problems with the dating scene is
that there are far too many options
which are arranged far too conveniently
and superficially on dating apps for you
to scroll through like you're shopping
for a mate on amazon or something we've
talked about the familiar uh irony of
modern life where the surplus of choices
tends to paralyze us it breeds
indecision and anxiety you know you're
afraid to pick one thing because you're
aware that there are a million other
options
how can you know that this is the right
one
why not just hold out for the next one
and the one after that the one after
that forever
now i'm far from the first person to
point this out as much as i'd like to
take credit for the insight i certainly
can't the paradox of choice is something
that many cultural critics and analysts
have noticed over the years in fact one
of them wrote a book called the paradox
of choice about this very problem
specifically as it relates to consumers
another book that touches on these
themes which i read a few months ago is
called the world beyond your head by
matthew crawford which i highly
recommend
and he talks about how craftsmen will
use
a strategy called jigging which
intentionally limits or constrains their
environment so they can work in a more
focused and efficient way
so again we see the paradox limitations
can be freeing in that they enable you
to accomplish one particular task
achieve one particular goal
in an environment specifically and
specially designed for it
what we find is that in a world without
limitation where everyone can do
everything
nobody ends up doing anything
i think this is part of the story with
dating
i also mentioned as one brief aside that
arranged marriages
which is a system that has been in place
historically in many cultures
uh that exists on the opposite end of
this spectrum they are the extreme
antithesis of our current approach to
dating i said that even that
even arranged marriages
would be preferable to our current
system
and not too surprisingly that is the one
single sentence in a 14-minute
discussion of dating that the left has
latched on to so first media matters
publish their urgent headline daily wire
host endorses arranged marriages it is
without a doubt superior to our system
that's quoting me
then my good friend jason campbell over
at media matters posted the clip to
twitter and from there some of the
left-wing blogs and youtube channels
picked it up and as a consequence of all
of this my inbox this morning was full
of some very interesting commentary much
of it revolving around the theme that i
am a horrible backwards archaic caveman
and i deserve to die a painful and
humiliating death
so really just your average wednesday i
suppose
of course contrary to the claims made by
my critics here i didn't say that
arranged marriages are the best option
just that they're better than our
current system which i'll say again
because it's true
i also think that literally anything
would be better than our current system
a national lottery pulling names out of
a hat and pairing couples up that way
would be better
you could have someone in fact all
volunteer for this job you could have
someone just walk down the street and
point to random people like you marry
her you two get married and that would
be better
which speaks not to the wisdom of that
alternative but to the disastrous nature
of our modern approach
best system the one that i actually do
advocate for is as i said courtship
you might call that dating with a
purpose goal-oriented dating whatever
label you want to put on the point is
that couples begin dating with the goal
of marriage in mind now i've been
criticized quite a bit for that
suggestion as well because it is i'm
told old-fashioned
out of touch reactionary
and i'll gladly embrace all those labels
but one of the great advantages of the
courtship courtship system
is that at the moment that either member
in this partnership realizes that they
cannot or do not do not want to marry
the other person the relationship is
broken off the marital interview process
is concluded and both can now go and
seek different applicants they don't
have to waste so much of their time
because there is a determined end point
which is either marriage
or not marriage
and once you realize you've you've
you've gotten to that point
or you're going to be a marriage or you
know that there's not going to be any
marriage
now you can move to the next phase which
would be marriage or just
going your separate ways
now there's no guarantee
that anybody who adopts this strategy
will immediately find the love of their
lives and live happily ever after even
if you get married as we all know that
certainly is no guarantee that you'll
live happily ever after because you have
to live day by day and moment by moment
we don't live in like chunks where you
can just cross some kind of threshold
and announce well i've done this so now
the next 50 years of my life will be
happy and fulfilled
doesn't work that way if you want a
happy and fulfilled life or a happy and
fulfilled marriage
you have to make that choice every day
and renew it the next day and the next
day and the day after that forever and
ever
love is an act of will it's a choice
it's not merely an emotion
the emotional experience of love is if
anything a byproduct it's not the fuel
that keeps your marriage running
the fuel is the choice you both make to
serve each other sacrifice for each
other
and remain loyal and faithful
this is another problem is this over
emphasis on emotions where emotions our
emotional um
fulfillment on purely and emotional
level is the entire point for a lot of
people that's what they think
and the problem is that emotions come
and go they ebb and flow emotions are
fleeting
and so they they go off and they get
married and they're they're feeling the
the emotional rush the honeymoon we talk
about the honeymoon and uh these days we
say honeymoon and we're talking about
the week-long vacation that you take to
europe or a cruise or whatever but
traditionally honeymoon is a phase of
marriage early on
and that's when your emotions are are
kicked into uh
you know high gear and and all of those
things and there's this infatuation and
when that starts to settle down a little
bit people that are guided only by their
emotions they'll say oh well i guess
this wasn't the right one
in fact i just read an article about um
uh pamela anderson who unfortunately is
just divorced i think it's her fifth
husband
and for some reason i read the the
article and it quotes her or someone
familiar with her as saying that oh she
she realized that uh he's not the one
so she's like in her 60s now
and she just left her fifth guy
because he's not the one she's still
pursuing the one what what do you think
you're looking for you're looking for
someone who will
give you that emotional satisfaction
every second of the day forever and the
moment those emotions fade away for even
a moment then you say well this is not
the one for me
now in order to even get in the door and
have the chance to maintain a marriage
or or screw it up
you have to go into your dating quest
with a sense of purpose life in america
today
is plagued by purposelessness
you've heard me talk about this many
times because i think it's our i think
it's our central problem
this is related to the issue of there
being too many choices it makes that
problem all the worse because how are
you supposed to know how to navigate all
the choices and select the right option
if you don't know what you're looking
for or why you're looking for it in the
first place
americans are experiencing record levels
of despair and anxiety not because
there's some mysterious mental illness
going around but because many people
have no sense of meaning or purpose in
their lives
this attitude is brought into their
relationships and their pursuit of
relationships and it's why the dating
scene is so miserable and marriage rates
are plummeting
i suggest
that we restore our sense of meaning and
purpose
and that's a suggestion that is treated
as controversial by those who would
prefer for everyone to remain mentally
paralyzed and in despair
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well the pro-life movement has a lot of
momentum right now and it has to keep it
going and what better way to help that
than by supporting the charities and
causes that you care about even if the
supreme court were to strike down roe v
wade abortion will still exist in
america in many many states that's why
the pro-life movement continues and will
will always be necessary in our culture
charity mobile is the pro-life phone
company they partner with you to
automatically support the pro-life
pro-family charity of your choice with
five percent of your monthly plan price
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone and free
activation and free shipping when you
mention offer code walsh certain
restrictions apply charity mobile makes
it easy to switch as well you can keep
your existing phone number you might
even be able to keep your existing phone
as well but if you need a new phone no
problem there chady mobile has a variety
of options from the latest 5g phones to
low-cost smartphones and basic phones as
well
all of their monthly plans include
unlimited domestic minutes and messages
which can be shared by up to eight lines
on a family plan there are no contracts
no termination fees and no risk with a
30-day guarantee switch to charity
mobile at support the causes you care
about call them at 1-877-474-3
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh
all right we'll start with this from fox
8 maybe you've heard this story but
here's the latest a woman who came into
close contact with an escaped monkey on
the side of an interstate in
pennsylvania said she developed pink
eye-like symptoms and is now on
preventative medication
wonderful
a truck hauling 100 monkeys from africa
was headed to a lab in missouri when it
collided with a dump truck on fri friday
at uh on route 54 at interstate 80 in
valley township michelle fallon of
danville said she pulled over to help
the driver
fallon said i thought i was just doing
the right thing by helping i had no idea
it would turn out this way he just asked
if his trailer was okay he never said if
you do come to your crate don't touch it
if he would have told me that i would
have been more careful
that's when she came face to face with
an agitated monkey which hissed in her
face
three monkeys and all in all escaped
during the ordeal during the search
officials warned the public not to come
near the monkeys because they would
transmit disease
she said quote i was close to the
monkeys i touched the crates i walked
through their feces so i was very close
so i called to inquire was i safe and um
then apparently she was told by the cdc
that uh you know well basically the cdc
told her yeah maybe not you might not be
safe actually so monitor your symptoms
and um and she has now she's developing
symptoms so
fantastic now
a couple couple things here
just a good rule of thumb that um
hopefully
it will never most of us won't get to a
point where we're going to have to
actually put this into action but a good
rule of thumb if you do encounter a
situation like this is um
don't help clean up spilled monkeys on
the highway
that's a that's a good rule now i do put
a lot of the blame on the driver here
he's the one that got into the accident
and also he didn't think to mention
when some woman
gets out of her car and comes over and
says hey how you doing everything okay
and then he he asks her
if everything's okay in the back of the
truck and doesn't even mention oh by the
way
this truck is full of virus-infected
monkeys so get the hell away from us
so i put a lot of the blame on him and i
don't mean to victim blame here but the
moment that you see
that there are cages with animals inside
them
don't go anywhere near them just get in
your car and drive away
uh there there are people who are
supposed to be equipped to deal with
these kinds of situations and it's not
you
i think the great the greater issue here
is that
this is
that we know of
at least maybe the third
occasion where potentially a virus has
escaped from um a lab or a virus that
was headed to a lab escapes on its way
there
we know about the big one in wuhan
and there are some very good indications
that uh although no one has told us this
and they probably never will officially
tell us just like they haven't
officially admitted it in wuhan and
never will but there are indications
that uh omnicorn escaped from a lab or
somehow got out of a lab in in south
africa
and now we've got this here
so this this is what this is what
gets me
uh if i want to build
a patio in my backyard i need to get 37
permits to do it
because of all the the safety concerns
apparently of having a patio in my own
backyard at our old house
we were doing renovations inside our
home
and somebody from the county showed up
because i guess
a very helpful neighbor noticed that we
had a lot of
construction workers and things coming
in and out of the house and and they
decided very helpfully to call the
county and alert them and so this guy
from the county shows up saying hey what
are you guys doing here what's going on
what am i doing here um it's none of
your business
it's in our house get the hell off my
property
you creep
so that's what happens if you try to you
know do anything in your own home try to
build a patio
uh
you know renovate inside or outside of
your home
god forbid you try to build some kind of
extension on your home
the permitting process for that is
basically impossible
probably 90 percent of people and i know
this from experience who've even thought
about building any kind of addition or
extension on their home 90 percent
probably give up
because once they realize how many
permits they have to get just to do it
and how expensive and complicated the
process is
so that's what if you want to you know
that's that's everyday life for just
regular americans even in your own home
then you talk to business owners
all the red tape they have to clear all
the permits and licenses and everything
they have to get and then get renewed
and everything else all of the
ridiculous oversight the bureaucracies
they have to navigate
and yet these virus labs are allowed to
just
deposit
dangerous pathogens all over the planet
and no one just there's no
accountability
nobody even gets a fine
has anybody even been fined has there
even been like a fifty dollar fine
for killing five million people
by letting the virus out in wuhan has
that has that even happened
and now you've got
monkeys that all have viruses and you
put them in the back of just a truck
a regular truck and and bring it down
the highway
and there's no
there's no oversight process there
apparently
i guess that's that's you know that's
less dangerous than me building a patio
or me building a fence that's over four
feet tall or whatever the arbitrary
limit is for when you're perfect for
those things
all right um so at the mandate at the
anti-mandate protest on sunday rfk jr
upset some people when he
made a holocaust
comparison and we know now that
holocaust comparisons are suddenly no
longer acceptable
so that's another change in the rules so
you can update your rule book but first
let's listen to what he said on sunday
even in hitler germany you could you
could cross the alps into switzerland
you can hide in an attic like anne frank
did
i visited in 1962 east germany with my
father
and met people who had climbed the wall
and escaped so it was possible many died
drewing it but it was possible
today
the mechanisms are being put in place
and we'll make it so none of us can run
and none of us can hide
the
within five years we're going to see 415
000 low orbit satellites
bill gates says his 65 000 satellites
alone will be able to look at every
square inch of the planet 24 hours a day
they're putting in 5g
to harvest our data and control our
behavior
digital currency that will allow them to
punish us from a distance and cut off
our food supply
vaccine passports
okay so he makes the the holocaust
analogy and
oh you're you're not allowed to do that
anymore apparently but well
it very much depends on what you're
talking about because as we know the
left in the media
spent four years
every single day multiple times a day
there was probably not a there was not
an occasion
over four years
there was not not a day went by
where you could turn on cable news cnn
or some or msnbc and not hear
some kind of hitler or holocaust or nazi
analogy related to uh
trump and his supporters
so they can do that but now and they'll
still do it as it relates to trump and
his supporters and conservatives in
general
yet god
forbid
anyone on the right or anyone in in an
unsanctioned way draws a history a
holocaust analogy not only is will they
say it's inaccurate
but it's somehow
unbelievably
unthinkably offensive
and it's anti-semitic they say
which let's let's just get let make one
thing very clear here
um
the majority of the holocaust analogies
and hitler analogies that are made
across the ideological spectrum the
majority of them
are
oftentimes off base and ridiculous
it doesn't make them anti-semitic
because the reason why people draw these
analogies there's two reasons why these
are the most common analogies that
people draw
um
and
one is that it's a it's a bad thing so
the person making the analogy that
there's there's something bad that they
don't like and so they're trying to
highlight how bad it is by comparing it
to this other very bad thing
now you could disagree with the analogy
on historical grounds
but the point is not to diminish the
severity of the holocaust the point is
to emphasize the severity of this other
thing they're comparing it to
even if they're wrong it's not
anti-semitic and the other reason why
these analogies come up so often is that
uh you know most people
don't have a very comprehensive
understanding of even recent history
there's only there are only a few
historical events that most people even
know about
enough to draw any kind of analogy and
world war ii and hitler is one of them
so that's why those analogies come up
this is how silly it is
that
you know if you were to say
you know if you compare something to a
concentration camp for example
and again only if you're on the right so
that's that's the qualification here we
know that but if you're on the right
and you compare something to
concentration camps
um
that's oh you can't do that that's
horrible that's that's the worst thing
in the world yet you you could compare
you know take the exact same thing and
and talk about compared to the gulags
and say oh they're gonna start shipping
us off to the gulags eventually
and somehow that's not offensive
when stalin
um
killed more people than hitler did
tens of millions of people were murdered
by the soviet regime
and you could draw those comparisons
perfectly fine for some reason
there was just uh there was a guest on i
saw the
the video on twitter this morning there
was a guest on um oh here it is yeah a
guest on cnn who said that virginia
has become a soviet-style police state
and the reason of course is the
soviet-style police state is that uh
glenn younkin allows kids to go to
school without a mask on
now putting aside how absurd that
comparison is it's like the opposite
right this is this is a him withdrawing
him saying no the government is not
going to force you to cover your face
when you go out in public now
this is more freedom
and so more freedom equals a soviet stop
police state but even putting that aside
so that's a
we're allowed to draw those comparisons
again the soviet-style police state
killed tens of millions of people
but
nonetheless people were very upset about
this and even
rfk junior's
wife cheryl hines who's uh i guess a
hollywood actress and i know she's on
curb your enthusiasm and maybe she's
been on other stuff as well but she put
out a tweet yesterday morning
and it says my husband's reference to
anne frank at a mandate rally in dc was
reprehensible and insensitive
the atrocities that millions endured
during the holocaust should never be
compared to anyone or anything
his opinions are not a reflection of my
own
should never be compared to anyone or
anything
yet this is i'm guessing the first such
comparison even though those comparisons
are made every single day on cable news
and on the internet this is the first
such comparison that she's been offended
by
not to mention should never be i i agree
that it's too often compared to to um
other things but never
so there's nothing that could ever
happen that would be analogous to it
uh and then robert f kennedy jr not long
after that says i apologize for my
reference to anne frank especially to
families that suffered the holocaust
horrors my intention was to use examples
of past barbarism to show the perils
from new technologies of control
to the extent my remarks caused hurt i
am truly and deeply sorry
well you know how i feel about the
public apology perfect example of why
that's a genre which should be abolished
he's apologizing to the people that he's
hurt he hasn't heard anybody nobody was
actually hurt by this
who's the who's the person there's no
way you could survive in modern america
or especially on the internet
if you're hurt
by
uh
you know hyperbolic
holocaust comparisons
considering they're all over the place
so nobody was hurt by that i apologize
to those who who i hurt well you didn't
hurt anybody
they were happy okay
they were happy for the opportunity they
were pleased with it
because there's this huge global march
against mandates and for freedom
and um
they don't like that they don't like the
fact that so many people are coming
together over this issue
across the ideological spectrum in fact
and they're looking for a way to change
the subject and for a reason to be
offended and you gave it to them so
they're happy they're very happy that
you that you made that comparison
but apologizing to the mob on your own
behalf is bad enough
apologizing to the mob on your spouse's
behalf
is uh takes it to a new level of
pathetic and cowardly
you know maybe this again maybe goes to
me being old-fashioned
you know i guess i was just raised a
little bit differently but
you never denounce your family or your
spouse in public
ever i don't care what they said
especially not over something like this
but i don't give a damn what he said
it could have been the worst thing
anyone's ever said about anything
you don't go in front of the
mob
and
denounce your own husband
how about some loyalty
how about some faithfulness
you've got a problem you pull your
spouse aside and talk to him in person
you don't you don't throw your spouse to
the wolves and say oh get him not me man
that's that's not me we're different
so much for uh to death do we part i
suppose
um
that's
it and again it does it doesn't even
matter what he said
and this is also a very good lesson here
um because
a really good case study because she she
comes out denounces her husband and bows
before the mob
and says i'm not with him i mean i'm
married to him but i'm not with him
and you read the comments under that
tweet from the left and are any of them
satisfied
you take a guess
are any of them saying okay well all
right i'm glad that you denounced him
you two are separated we're just mad at
him not you but you're good
is anyone saying that no
every single one of them saying that's
that's not enough this is too too little
too late you shouldn't have married him
in the first place
you really want to prove something to us
now you have to divorce him
divorce him and then come talk
and she might in fact do that and when
she does that of course that's not going
to be enough either
it's the same story we've seen a million
times you try to appease the mob
and not only is that a cowardly and
pathetic move but it's also
futile
you know even if you could appease the
mob by throwing your spouse under the
bus it would still be the wrong thing to
do
but you can't even appease them anyway
it won't work
so you might as well just be loyal then
all right i missed this yesterday but
this is great
from the daily wire
it says it sounds like spotify will need
to choose a side musician neil young
issued a bold ultimatum and a now
deleted message to his management team
and record label the letter said the 76
year old musician was planning to refuse
the
music streaming service access to his
catalog of albums until they cut ties
with podcast host joe rogan
young shared in the letter quote please
act on this immediately today and keep
me informed of the time schedule i want
you to let spotify know immediately that
i want all my music off their platform
they can have joe rogan or young not
both
now
joe rogan is
by far the biggest attraction on uh on
spotify he makes them hundreds of
millions of dollars whereas neil young
makes them i don't know hundreds of
dollars
at most
this is like me storming into jeremy's
office and saying listen you can have
ben shapiro or me
shapiro or walsh not both
okay we'll take ben then definitely
oh well uh
you know what never mind forget we had
this conversation
and the other great thing here is that
apparently
neil young doesn't even own his
catalogue he sold the rights to his
catalogue
so
not only is he making an ultimatum he's
he's making that probably the least
effective threat in the history of
threats
but he doesn't have the right to make
the threat because he does not own his
own music that's what happens when you
sell the rights to the catalog
good stuff from uh from neil young
yet another aging hippie by the way who
used to pretend to be um
you know against the system and the man
and all of that
and now he's coming out strongly and in
support of the man
all right camila harris speaking
who knows where or why uh i don't think
that matters
well she's at the white house but what
is she talking about i don't know here's
what she had to say
we are focused on the most vulnerable
and based on my experience the most
vulnerable
are women and girls
racial and ethnic minorities
lgbtqia plus people
indigenous people
people with disabilities
migrants
and children in the foster care system
when we identify who is most vulnerable
we can tailor our tactics
and improve our strategy
okay so the most vulnerable people are i
think i have the list here
um and this is based on her experience
she says so she knows it's based on her
experience uh the most vulnerable are
women and girls
but what are those she she wouldn't be
able to tell us that
racial and ethnic minorities
lgbtqi plus people indigenous people
people with disabilities migrants
and children in the foster care system
so in other words
um everyone everyone is the most
vulnerable person except
straight white males and it'd be a lot
easier and quicker to just come out and
say that
i i am here to protect and i care about
everyone except straight white males
and i guess there's one other group
which will be children in the womb now
notice how she says she doesn't just say
children
which in fact children are a vulnerable
group um that's that's one category of
person that belongs in this in this uh
in this list
uh most of the rest of them
don't lgbt people are are vulnerable
in in what way
certainly not vulnerable to any kind of
systemic oppression
these are the most
celebrated
and visible people
pound for pound
of any group in america
probably in the history of the united
states there has never been such a
concerted all-encompassing effort
to specifically celebrate and prop up
any group of people the way that we do
with lgbt
um and uh a similar thing can be said
for many other groups children though
are a vulnerable group
but she's very specific about it she
says children in the foster care system
which agreed they're vulnerable too very
vulnerable
what about children in the womb
they have no legal rights whatsoever
their moral worth is not recognized
by many people in this country it's not
recognized by the legal system
they have zero human rights
60 million of them have been executed
they have been subject to the
worst um
mass
execution
systematic execution
in history
so but those are the two that we're
leaving out straight white men and uh
and
women uh children in the womb rather
all right one other thing here a report
on insider.com that was making the
rounds yesterday online
it says black teachers are overwhelmed
by increased responsibilities at schools
and it's making some quit the profession
we go to the article it says circling
the school hallways reminding students
throughout the day to raise their masks
over their nose and mouth has become
xavier mcdougall's new normal the san
francisco teacher told insider that
every time he walks into the school he
teaches at he's on patrol duty as the
mask enforcer his health and his
students health are critical he told
insider that's why he doesn't understand
why there is a national debate during
the most infectious point of the
pandemic so far on whether students and
teachers should be ushered back into the
classroom
mcdougald said
i feel like a lot of administration is
choosing not to see it from a teacher's
perspective people are still getting
coveted it was hard teaching online but
i just think it's more worth it to stay
online
yeah more worth it to you to stay online
because you say it was hard teaching
online it wasn't hard for you
you get to stay home you get a glorified
vacation
it um
and it's kind of all the same to you
especially if you don't really care now
for teachers who actually care about
their kids
and are worried about the information
getting across and the kids absorbing
the information for those teachers
online teaching was very very difficult
and i've heard from many teachers like
that
it brought them a lot of distress to
know how futile all of this was and the
fact that that these kids are not
absorbing the information they're not
getting what they need
but to somebody like this doesn't really
care about the kids and is totally
self-centered as is already obvious from
everything we've heard here
um it's teaching online was not hard at
all it was hard on the kids
but there's also a question of why
why the focus on black teachers here
when does this become racial let's keep
let's keep reading
um
let's see insider spoke to black
teachers who said the last two years
have been the hardest of their careers
they've become the mask enforcers
juggled heated discussions on education
curriculum and they've become the
on-the-job racial sensitivity educators
after the murder of george floyd
nikita gibbs nolan said when this
pandemic first hit i was actually as the
uh union rep having weekly meetings with
teachers to ask how are you doing
because it was so overwhelming to some
people
some people were considering quitting
some people were fearful of going back
and then going on more complaints
mcdougall said from microaggressions
triggered by supervisors to clogs and
career advancements simply because of
how they run their classroom for black
teachers it has always been difficult
and now with the pandemic teachers told
insider it's worth
worse rather in the study black teachers
said administrators didn't acknowledge
their contributions and peers questioned
their intelligence and curriculum
choices or viewed their assertiveness as
anger
mcdougall said in his experience after
floyd's murder he spent a lot of time
educating the predominantly white staff
at his school on cultural competency but
they didn't put the information into
practice
quote i felt like it's been mostly my
responsibility to fill in the gaps i
also feel like it's an extra burden to
be a disciplinarian and as a black male
that teaches i'm tall and i have a
deeper voice i do try to use it to my
advantage okay so
this is a poor guy you know he he was
educating the other adults around him
telling them what they're supposed to do
and and some of them didn't do it
he was instructing the other adults the
white people
and and they have to listen to him
because they're white
and and probably a lot of them did but
but some of them
can you believe what this man has to go
through in his life
that there are some white people who who
he could he could look them right in the
eye and tell them what to do and what to
think and they still refuse to do it
truly no one has suffered like this man
or woman i forget who it is
and then also the complaints about oh
they are our our contributions aren't
being recognized
you know there's misunderstandings at
work sometimes when i assert myself
people accuse me of being angry hey look
i've got news for you here
that's the case for every person on
earth
every person especially every person at
every job
in every profession in every position
feels as though their contributions
aren't being sufficiently recognized
that's everyone
and also for every person
when you try to assert yourself
sometimes it can come off as angry i
know that from experience
so these are
as we often see
universal facts of the human experience
and yet
because everything's put into a racial
framework
now someone who's bought into the racial
framework
if they're part of a racial minority and
they experience one of these universal
facts of human existence one of the more
uncomfortable facts of human existence
they they immediately assume because
this is the framework that they have
that oh it must be it must be racism
even though every white person
experiences it too when it happens to me
it has to be racism
a certain illogic to that i would say
well if you've ever experienced nausea
and vomiting which i think everyone has
at some time or another uh whether for
motion sickness anxiety morning sickness
or another condition you you know how
quickly your body can turn from calm and
balance to a red alert crisis mode and
if you are afflicted by the special
condition of motion sickness and cars
like i am uh you know how
anxiety-inducing that can be when you
feel like you have to hurl and you're in
the back of an uber or something they
probably won't appreciate it that's why
i've got great news relief ben is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that's been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness and anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy and
provides all-natural long-lasting
release with relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed how it
works is relief band stimulates a nerve
in the wrist that travels to the part of
your brain that controls nausea then it
blocks the signal your brain is sending
to your stomach telling you that you're
sick it sounds complicated but uh it's
actually simple you just put the relief
band on and the nausea goes away makes
for a great gift any time of year right
now they've got an exclusive offer just
for matt walsh listeners if you go to
reliefband.com and use promo code walsh
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and a no questions asked 30 day money
back guarantee so head to
reliefband.com and use our code walsh
for 20 off plus free shipping
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
all right if you want to leave a video
comment or submit a video comment you
can go to dailywire.com sweet baby
comments and let's go to the uh
video and start with clip 9.
hey matt we are on day six of homeschool
we decided to pull out our four kids
ages eleven ten eight and seven
um thanks to a lot of the stuff that we
heard just giving us the confidence to
make that switch
and i wanted to share a short story with
you that when we went to pick up our
kids from school and all their supplies
i've stopped by one of the teachers
classrooms and she asked if my son could
come back for the honor roll celebration
that they would be having off campus
because they weren't allowed to have it
on campus this year and when i asked her
why that was as the celebration was
usually on campus she had told me that
our school had done away with honor roll
because it was making kids feel bad who
did not make the honor roll
that just
gave me even more confidence in our
decision to pull them out and just
wanted to get your thoughts on the lack
of
observing excellence
and promoting greatness and rewarding
those kids who work hard and do well
sbg for life
you know first of all um my house sounds
exactly like your house so it's always
refreshing to to hear other parents in
their natural environment um with
children running around and screaming
like uh like jungle animals in the
background because that's my house as
well so i do appreciate that as for the
rest of it
congratulations on embarking on your
homeschool journey there there are a lot
of reasons why this will be better than
public school but the thing you
mentioned is certainly one reason
um
where excellence is not rewarded or
encouraged in the public school system
the way that it should be and the way
that uh maybe at one time it used to be
but it's kind of a twofold problem
because yes schools are often no longer
rewarding and recognizing excellence
they're trying to smash
everyone together in the mediocre middle
and um anyone who pokes their head above
the rest gets chopped down like a weed
in the grass
so that's happening and that's a problem
but then also
to the extent that they do still
recognize
excellence i don't really trust
their ability to actually
identify excellence in the right way
because i i think it's i think it's
better to have these kinds of programs
and have different tracks for kids so
that the ones who are really excelling
can move at a faster pace i think it's
better to have it than to not have it
especially especially given the reason
for abolishing this stuff
um or or de-emphasizing it the reason is
we want to hurt people's feelings so
it's better to have it
but even um
even when you do have it and back when i
was in school
most of these things are
were determined by you know standardized
testing and that sort of thing
and there's a problem there too because
there are a lot of
really intelligent talented
kids with very bright futures
who just don't perform well on tests
they perform well academically but
they're not great testers
and the school system
doesn't have any way of um at least with
the with its way it's currently
constructed they don't have any way of
of analyzing kids or measuring them
aside from just that are you able to
regurgitate the information on this
sheet of paper
and if you can't then
you know we lump you into one category
the people that can regurgitate are in
another category
so there's always multiple layers to all
the problems you have in public school
which is a good reason to homeschool all
right let's uh go to clip 14.
hey sdw
um i'm heaven child my video is coming
in a little bit late
i really had to think about whether or
not i wanted to
further boost your ego by proving once
again that you're always right
so the other day
i was listening to your show just
driving around running my errands
and i was wholeheartedly just
disagreeing with you
um regarding your comments about women
being terrible drivers like i did not
agree
and
i thought you were totally off base with
that well
i then proceeded
to hit the curb
and once again i was shown that you were
always right about everything so please
don't cancel me for doubting you
and um
that's it spg for life
uh well that's good the first step is to
realize that you have a problem though i
i think um
maybe one way to solve this problem is
to identify as a man i mean that that
that's really the ultimate experiment
here i guess is can a man if we can a
man really become a woman chemical can a
woman become a man
well if you if you change your
self-identity
and then discover that you suddenly
drive without slamming into curbs
that might actually prove me wrong about
the whole
gender question so it'll be interesting
to experiment uh and that's uh let's go
to where's the one i wanted here um
where is it
uh
12.
hi
i'm casey and i'm 14 years old i'm
audrey i'm 12 and we're both
homeschooled and we live in the
shenandoah mountains an hour away from
the nearest grocery store because we
live in the mountains there aren't
roving bands of mobs patrolling the
streets
and obviously my sister and i aren't on
social media so we don't get much
hands-on experience debating liberals
any suggestions for how we can improve
our debating skills
also are you accepting interns at the
daily wire
i guess that's all
let's go brandon and spg for life so you
guys are living the dream
congratulations on that i mean that's
how you know you're off the grid by the
way if you're if that you're off the
beaten path is you can judge it by your
proximity to a grocery store now as far
as tips on debating leftists the first
thing i mean what i would say honestly
is that uh you're what 12 and 14 so
uh you're living the good life out in
the woods in nature you're away from all
this stuff
you're not on social media which i love
to hear so
i would actually say don't don't worry
about debating the leftists right now
it's not part of your life it doesn't
need to be right now there will come a
time for it but i wouldn't worry about
it
you don't need to debate anyone
enjoy your childhood you only have it
for a few more years
that's my that's my advice
all right um
a couple written comments here's one
that says matt what's your take on
wordle
i i don't know i have no idea what that
is maybe someone can explain it to me i
see it all over twitter i have no idea
what it is my pattern is that i usually
figure out what a new fad is eve about
you know about three minutes before it's
no longer
a thing so the moment that i even figure
out what it is that means that uh people
are just gonna move to the next thing
um
let's see
heath says how is it that the handsome
and brilliant matt walsh doesn't have at
least one million subscribers just for
the sarcasm alone is enough to watch or
listen i'm being oppressed that's why
jasmine says i have to say i actually
disagree with matt when he said he would
make a new office and toss out the
diversity and inclusion one in virginia
abortion disproportionately is directed
at black and latino communities and
diversity is a great thing to have among
the living so we should definitely work
towards more diversity in life by not
killing the unborn in those diverse
communities well your your point
you exactly prove my point i think in
the way that you phrase that um
there are a lot of very good reasons to
not kill babies
and yes i suppose that when you kill
babies you are
decreasing
diversity
but that is not at all
the point
the reason you shouldn't kill babies is
because they're human beings and it is a
moral atrocity to intentionally and
directly kill innocent and defenseless
human beings that's why you shouldn't do
it
it's it's a great moral evil
and so in trying to
put this within the leftist framework
and use their language
you end up undermining your own point
there's just no reason to do it who
cares about diversity we're talking
about mass murder here
so that's my point so thanks for the
comment the next episode of adam
corolla's comedy series truth yeller
airs tomorrow adam is joined by silicon
valley actor and comedian tj miller who
wears a very short clip-on tie and
you've got to tune in to see that he
also takes no prisoners check it out
we got a guy up here that has a shirt on
that says do not comply
and so i don't have
yeah that's right
and that's nice because i don't have to
ask if you've been vaccinated or if you
care about the elderly or anything like
that
i already know from your shirt i'm like
he'd kill my grandmother and not think a
second time about it
he would just go home get high and pop
in the vhs tape
of adam's unborn children
so head to dailywire.com subscribe and
use code miller for 25 off your
membership look out for the new episode
with tj miller dropping tomorrow also
if it's true it's probably not getting
published daily wire is changing that
with our own publishing wing dw books
and we're proud to be publishing two
books that are actively fighting the
left's monopoly on storytelling the
first is 12 seconds in the dark by
sergeant mattingly the book is the true
story of what really happened in
the night of the tragic brianna taylor
shooting mattingly a 20-year police
veteran takes readers inside his
department's response and debunks the
lies that have recklessly been shared
with the public so you'll find out the
truth about that story you got to pick
out that book also dw books is
publishing fiery but mostly peaceful by
julio rosas who pulls back the curtain
and sets the record straight on the
black lives matter riots that broke out
across the country in 2020 roses who was
reporting from the ground during all
this gives his first hand experience at
the riots and exposes the media's
attempts to convince americans that the
fatal and destructive riots were somehow
peaceful
i'm grateful to have these brave
truth-tellers on board and can't wait
for you to hear their stories both are
available to pre-order right now on
amazon or anywhere you buy books online
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so peter dinklage is a hollywood actor
and a little person a person of short
stature an individual of less than
average height a human of smaller
persuasion i'm not sure what the
politically correct term is these days i
think dwarf is still okay though for
some reason [ __ ] has been thrown out
in any case well you could choose which
label makes you feel the most
comfortable what matters today is that
dinklage is bravely speaking out against
the woke snow white remake currently in
the works over at disney although his
complaint is that it's not nearly woke
enough obviously now as we know disney
has been diligently focused on ripping
off degrading mutating mutilating
destroying all of their own classics and
not just their classics either even
their middle tier cartoons like the
aristocats have been placed on the
docket for remakes in this case a live
action remake i'm told
it's not exactly clear how a movie about
talking cats could be live action but
you know
that's neither here nor there snow white
is a little bit easier to reimagine in
that format
and to wokify
so the new version will feature disney's
first latina
excuse me la tinx disney princess
the non-white princess will play a
character who is named snow white
literally because according to the
original fairy tale her skin is white as
snow
now recasting a character like this with
a non-white actress
it's like recasting black panther with
chris pat pratt in the in the lead role
of course if disney did something like
that
there would be riots in the street
al sharpton would rappel down from a
helicopter and hold a press conference
denouncing them
it would be unthinkably offensive to
cast a white actor in a traditionally
non-white role whereas it is unthinkably
offensive to complain about the reverse
happening those are the rules
and yet none of this is enough to
satisfy peter dinklage
who took some time on mark maron's wtf
podcast to complain about the
insufficient wokeness of disney's woke
snow white let's listen
i was a little
taken back by the
very very they're very proud to cast a
a latino actress as snow white yeah but
you're still telling the story of snow
snow white yeah seven dwarfs sure
look take take a step back and look at
what you're doing there makes no sense
to me well oh so
you're progressive in one way and then
but you're still making that
backward oh story about seven dwarves
living in a cave
what the are you doing man we you know
have i have i done nothing to advance
the cause
from my soapbox
i guess i'm not loud enough
uh
i don't know what she's doing i don't
know what studio that is but but it was
they were so proud of that and all love
and respect to the to the actress and to
the people who thought they were doing
the right thing but i'm just like you
know what are you doing
there we go snow white is offensive to
dwarfs
now the film uh i guess i don't know the
film commits some literal micro
aggressions you might say though it must
be noted that contrary to dinklage's
claims the dwarves in snow white they
don't live in a cave first of all they
live in a charming cabin in the woods
they work in a cave
which is actually a mine where they
apparently discovered a rather lucrative
mineral deposit and they enjoy mining
those resources which is why they
whistle while they work
but perhaps more to the point
the dwarves and fairy tales like snow
white just like the dwarves and fantasy
stories like the lord of the rings are
not
disabled humans who suffer from dwarfism
they're mythical creatures they're like
leprechauns or elves in these stories if
you're going to be offended by mythical
characters because of a vague physical
resemblance
then brian stelter should be offended by
humpty dumpty nancy pelosi should be
offended by cruella deville bill de
blasio should be offended by the muppets
but you don't see them complaining
but you do see them complaining just not
about that now this is all to say
nothing of the fact that dinklage
has already played mythical dwarves in
films many times
he also appeared in the movie elf for
just one scene where the whole joke was
that will ferrell's character thought he
was an elf from the north pole
now this kind of moral hypocrisy is of
course quite common among the woke
especially the older woke many of whom
just decided recently to adopt this
stance over the past like five years
after a lifetime of relative sanity
they've now decided that they could act
a certain way and do certain things and
make certain jokes and indulge in
certain stereotypes and make money in
certain ways but nobody else is allowed
to do it
their views have evolved and now they
have no patience for anyone who fails to
evolve along with them
people who carry on exactly as they did
just 12 seconds ago are persona non
grata i mean what if there were younger
dwarfs like dinklage once was
who were looking forward to the snow
white remake because it would be their
chance to break into the film industry
just as he did
sorry says dinklage that path was open
to him
but it now has to be closed to everybody
else
he's drawing up the bridge behind him no
one else sorry pulling up the ladder
he was the last one through the door
he's locking it behind him and then he's
turning around
staring out the window and sneering at
everybody still stuck outside
and it looks like he'll get his way the
hollywood reporter has a disney
statement about all this quote to avoid
reinforcing stereotypes from the
original animated film we're taking a
different approach with these seven
characters and have been consulting with
members of the dwarfism community we
look forward to sharing more as the film
heads into production after a lengthy
development period a disney spokesperson
said a statement to hollywood reporter
still years from release snow white will
have cultural consultants just like
other live-action films such as aladdin
and mulan
the film has been been in development
for three years the studio has been
reimagining the dwarf characters since
the earliest stages
yeah we wouldn't want uh stereotypes of
mythical creatures
perhaps next we can get a campaign to
end the stigma surrounding vampires and
werewolves
so to review
in the new snow white and the seven
dwarves
snow white will no longer be snow white
and the dwarves will no longer be doors
nothing can be what it was before all
that existed in the past is now
offensive simply because it existed in
the past
fairy tales especially
must be abolished and rewritten
as disney has set out to do and this is
why they're doing it well the first
reason they're doing it is for the money
the second is this
because fairy tales cannot be allowed to
continue existing fairy tales commit the
afro-mentioned sin of being very old and
that's no good also fairy tales deal
with universal themes and universal
themes are problematic because they
don't cater specifically enough to the
particular concerns of individual victim
groups
and fairy tales always revolve around a
conflict of good versus evil but that's
also offensive because the categories of
good and evil require moral judgment and
moral judgment is no longer allowed
moreover and the biggest thing of all is
that fairy tales quite often feature a
romance which is based in traditional
notions of chivalry and gender roles
obviously we can't have any of that
those are the defining elements of fairy
tales and very often the defining
elements of stories in general
that's why we have to move past it
it's time we move past storytelling
altogether abolish all films and
television shows and burn all books
we can spend our time sitting in silence
staring at blake blank screens and empty
pages
it's the only way to ensure
that nobody is ever offended
but in the meantime we have to say to
peter dinklage that he is of course
today canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
wadowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show wild
swings roil the stock market as the
federal reserve considers new rate hikes
plus the biden administration rolls back
its vax mandate finally that's today on
the bench bureau show give it a listen